let me just jump in here first of all
because I've SAT there for a long term
see playing playing extremely bad chess
beat me and secondly because I still
don't understand what we're actually
talking about when I say juice weasel
opl then I mean really if I'm honest a
feeling I feel at home under European
sky I feel at home with the landscapes
with the reflexes of the people with the
turns of phrase I also feel at home with
European values and as a philosopher no
I cannot give you an ultimate
metaphysical nail to which I could nail
them but I feel at home with them now
that is one part of the conversation if
we talk about the European Union and
debt repayments then I'm first of all I
think much more pragmatic because I
think without a European Union we would
probably not be able to solve or it
indeed face any of the problems that
come our way in terms of climate change
international money markets migration
movements they're all the old
transnational move the trans national
problems no nation state can deal with
them so we need this kind of thing but
you say there really is the European
spirit and you know that is because
you're talking about an elite there is
no real european spirit among all
europeans because this European Union is
in a terrible crisis of political
legitimacy it has none it has not worked
for it that has been too elitist look at
this ridiculous moment with the European
Constitution when basically a former
French president was asked to draw up a
nice constitution which was almost the
200 pages long and very complex and then
people were given the choice between
saying yes or being bad Europeans if you
voted wrong you had to vote again until
you voted
and that's not how any democracy works
we could have voted a constitutional
assembly and let them get on with it and
draw up a constitution that would have
been our Constitution that would have
been rubbed remotely Democratic so I
think we're really talking about two
completely different things because when
I go back to the first part the feeling
European part then I'm not at all sure
whether Norwegians and Greeks and
Portuguese and poles feel the same in
their practices in their daily life in
their beliefs how much really does
connect us I think that's an open
question yes we have a history of wars
yes we have a history of Christianity
yes we all inhabit the same small
appendix of Asia but does that mean that
we really have a common identity you
know here would be a nice task for the
European Union mg foster such an
identity but at the moment it's failed
spectacularly I think you are very right
but I think there's one moment when we
can all unambiguously feel that European
identity and that's when we're outside
of Europe when I lived in the Middle
East I realized I was European and when
I came back to Europe five years later I
actually wasn't so sure it's easier to
feel European in Jerusalem or in Tokyo
then in Rome or even Berlin mrs. i think
it's the only place where you can feel
European outside Europe the reason why I
participate in these debates yeah its
first of all because there's no such a
thing as you p nationalism I think
nothing good can come out of nationalism
and I despise anti-european feelings a
bit more than the European feelings but
when you ask me why are you european
that's my my answer would be because I
moved a few years ago to New York what
else can I be in New York Bob European
I've no other choice and I'm quite happy
about it I'm not sure sir I've I like
many things Adam said because I love you
/ locations I think they're really smart
and intelligent and we said something
about we are months of your bell first
of all I don't know of
was did we are his country despite
earlier promises but I think what you
really wanted to say is that the the
piece is not only kept by the European
Union but also by the United States of
America if I understood you well let me
finish for unpacking sharing the screws
so and that's also why I think this
whole question about feelings or whether
we love Europe or not that's all a bit
gratuitous in the end at the end the
question is are we willing to die for
you and in knots what does it mean to
have this feeling of being European or
not and to be honest if you ask me are
you willing to die for europe-wide
willing to die for the United States of
America without realizing the US without
thinking that this is a better place I
would be tempted to say I would rather
die for us then for europe because i
think the continuation of Europe is in
Canada on us I think if I were a member
for minority in India in Europe I don't
have it okay explain how those I don't
see anything well of course the European
culture is American coach you cannot
separate it and I think in in many ways
the better place today for many
minorities fits boca Stannis in the
audience and I disagree with him on many
things he said but a few years ago in
New York he gave a talk and he said an
interesting and important thing is that
people vote with her feet so the fact
that so many people despite the
criticism of the US would like to go to
the US is study yesterday I talked to an
Afghan asylum seeker he said I asked him
why do you come to the Netherlands is
that because i could not find a human
trafficker who would bring me to the US
I would have rather gone to that but I
could not find one so this one I mean I
think in many ways if I would be a
Muslim I would want to go to through
Canada or the u.s. if I would be ben
adam i think this is the safe for the
better place and it's also why i think
this when i come back now and then you
can finish to your comments I think
nobody all love you but in the end
nobody is willing to die for you this a
movie made by Clint Eastwood came out a
couple of months ago American sniper
about the sniper fighting in Iraq it's
unthinkable that he would have a movie
German sniper for historical reasons
even touch is not here to Isis Isis in
Afghanistan accord
two American soldiers have been as you
know a few times the American to
Afghanistan I sub stands for I saw
Americans fighting and this basically
what you were saying really we have
peace because Americans are willing to
die for us and are willing to fight for
us and we are not going to do it for
four good reasons and dying is not not a
nice thing but it is a bit problematic
that we are talking about Europe without
being willing to die for it you can
almost feel perspective well but but i
have to say that that the one place
where you really feel European is in the
American Midwest
you know forget Tokyo yeah well my view
is a little complicated because I've got
got into Europe via the United Kingdom
and before the the European Union was
really create properly so I'm not at all
surprised about the developments at the
moment to see that country go back to
acccess because it's never left itself
so my job there was to import
continental culture to the UK coming
from being born in the Middle East so
the very complicated route in there so
for me being European is a strange
notion when i was 12 i said to my
parents I don't believe that Europe
exists you have to take me that I want
to see it otherwise I'll never believe
it exists I'd never been and then I was
brought to the heart of Europe to Munich
that was really the heart of Europe and
and and my my country is his culture so
I came here because I had the cultural
calling desire to connect with European
culture but at that time culture for me
was represented by Holy Fathers to use a
Christian term it was basically poet
artist specific people a lot of them
were still alive I was kind of really
coming on a pilgrimage towards something
very specific it's very interesting
because of course this discussion is
very political now but I think what is
also another level of the discussion is
the the destruction of culture through
the share drive of modernism and how in
fact you know between the birth of
mozart in the death of stockhausen we
have an era of culture which which is i
would call a culture of specifics and
after that we are entering into an era
where everything is now flat everything
is dominated by a kind of digital
energy which is which we are meant to
all bow to and and I often tried to kind
of put myself now that i have a small
child and I'm who's born here and has to
look back towards the east instead of me
looking to the west it gave me thoughts
about how what do I really want my child
to 22 what kind of cultural calling
would I like my child to have taken my
own journey and I'm very very concerned
extremely concerned because I think that
you know in the middle of this European
discussion there's also a discussion
about the this integration of what i
call the cultural specifics into
something into a morass of something
very vague in which we are we are meant
to one of the concepts that changes
completely is the concept of curiosity
because of course an intellectual is a
curious person it's a person who wants
to find out something about something
they don't know then related to other
levels of knowledge and create an
interaction and the debate like the one
we're having now and you know culture is
born from there and so this curiosity
notion is changed it's changed
completely because of course our
curiosity is on our computers now and
it's it's it's kind of boiled down to
something to complete different form of
energy
you